and welcome to hannity and tonight we
are broadcasting we are in music city
nashville tennessee
and the site of the republican governors
association
and their spring conference now for the
entire hour we're going to have an open
discussion
with six of the nation's top governors
about the state of our country
we'll take on immigration we'll talk
about the southern border
taxes law and order we'll also be
talking about what works in the states
and what i have been telling everybody
and been listing
as well what does it mean to be a
conservative what are the policies that
work for you
the american people the conservative
movement me it's simple
it's liberty it is freedom it is
capitalism our constitution including
our first and second amendment
low taxes limited government regulation
choice for
our kids in school oh we do need
integrity in elections that would be
voter id laws to begin with signature
verification
partisan observers that can observe and
of course secure borders
we believe in free-market solutions for
health care while protecting people with
pre-existing conditions
we believe in law and order without law
and order
guess what you can't pursue happiness
free and fair trade
election integrity uh constitutionalists
on the bench and peace through strength
for me that about sums it up and
hopefully the governors will
talk about what matters and what's been
working in their states
now what we'll tell you what we're
against as well
cancer culture defunding dismantling the
police
the so-called bail reform where you get
arrested they let you out the same day
without paying a dime
high regulations draconian coveted 19
shutdowns that are still
affecting so many people in the country
the democrats
on parties unholy alliance with the
teachers union
and allow me to spell out a few of the
basic undeniable facts
that even well if sippy cup is awake
which he's likely not
might he even be able to understand the
late
the fastest growing state in america by
percentage is the state of utah
the fastest growing state by sheer
numbers is the state of texas
the fastest growing region in the u.s is
the south when the pandemic hit millions
of americans they flocked to florida
and meanwhile new york california
illinois they all lost seats in the 2020
census
while states like texas and florida
north carolina
they all gain seats freedom
individualism
safety security key issues
related to your prosperity if
republicans you want to take back power
in washington
you want to stop this power grab that we
all talk about
the america first make america great
agenda i think needs to be articulated
by anybody and everybody running for
office
so without further ado joining us now
for the hour
we have new hampshire governor chris
sununu soon to be called senator
if he would take my recommendation but
apparently he's resistant
iowa governor rga vice chair kim
reynolds is with us
arizona governor rga chairman doug ducey
is here
florida governor ron desantis is with us
south dakota governor christie gnome
and the governor the great state of
tennessee that is hosting all of us
is governor bill lee and we're joined
also by
a live audience you are free to yell
anything you want at any time
okay
all right now with all of that said if
i'm going to be really blunt
forthright and honest with you uh i want
to get the hell out of new york
and i want to see which of you is going
to offer me the best deal uh
because i assure you oh you you're
jumping in right away sean you and i
have talked about this i have my dmv
on standby you will get a driver's
license minute we'll register your vote
this will happen very quickly you just
need to pull the trigger
all right we've been talking about this
for years i both probably getting over
10 years
but i also like mount rushmore and i
also like
country music you are here and i want to
be an iowa farmer
the only one who might lose out here is
arizona governor because that dry heat
thing is pretty awful
and governor sununu i already have your
diet for
you you're our host and go let's start
with you so
we have this mass migration from big
blue states
with high taxes burdensome regulation
draconian shutdowns and then we have
the republican governors that have very
different models let's talk about it
generally
yeah well our model you can see out
on broadway it's open our businesses are
open
people are going to restaurants they're
going to bars
there aren't any masks this pandemic
has been quite a distraction to all of
america for sure
to say the least but the health crisis
is over
the emergency is over we have
fully opened up and are moving our state
forward and the reason that we're doing
that is because we follow the science
and you know the left likes to say
follow the science until they don't yeah
you you can't
follow that you can't the vaccinated
judgment you can't
follow the science outdoors socially
distance
walking into jimmy carter's house with a
mask on then taking it off in front of
the old people
you can't yeah that was brilliant you
can't say follow science and keep kids
out of school
you can't say follow the science and
wear a mask after you're vaccinated or
you certainly can't put covid patients
back into nursing homes
if you follow the science thank you none
of you did that
thank you for having having enough sense
amazing governor noah
you were on the show regularly
throughout this pandemic
south dakota never shut down never uh we
didn't close a single business ever
we in fact in south dakota we didn't
even define what an essential business
was
because according to the oath i took to
the south dakota constitution the u.s
constitution
i didn't believe i had the authority to
tell anybody that their business wasn't
essential
i told my people i would trust them and
that i was going to let them use
personal responsibility to take care of
their families but
keep their doors open um provide for
their employees and their customers and
the people of south dakota uh you know
appreciated it we never issued a shelter
in place didn't mandate any masks or
anything and today we have the
fastest uh growing gdp in the fourth
quarter at 9.9 percent
in the country our unemployment's 2.8
percent
we have the least amount of jobs lost
businesses closed hours lost wages lost
from any employee in the country
and so what we did is we used
conservative principles that we all talk
about
all the time we've talked about them for
years we did them
and we're proving that it worked and so
that's really the story that i think we
need to tell about 2020
is that leadership has consequences and
you just look at democrat states
and what happened to families and
businesses there you look at republican
states
and how they're growing and they're
thriving and what all these leaders up
here did
how it works for the american people so
we talk about
statistics and facts all the time but
those stories are going to be powerful
when we uh change the majority in
washington dc and we change who's in the
white house
one interview very early on you said to
me i trust the people of my state
and i believe in them and it paid off
well for you
you know governor desantis so funny
because you got a little row or two with
your buddy andrew cuomo in new york and
you know i'm looking at these other
states that kids still aren't in school
florida schools have been open since
august
how is it possible they're watching you
do this successfully
and they still don't learn from it well
i think it's been
probably the biggest mistake tragedy is
locking these kids out of school they're
not following science this is politics
and ideology and quite frankly it's a
disgrace i was in baker county florida
they celebrated the 180th day of being
open the full school year they did the
full school year finished it
today from the very beginning and every
single parent from the beginning had the
right to send their kids
to school in person i think there's
obviously a lot of other policies that
really mattered obviously
we didn't we prevented up coveted
patients from being sent to nursing
homes we created covet only nursing
facilities to protect the most
vulnerable i think that that mattered
but i can tell you
locking kids out of school for over a
year that's going to have ramifications
for our country
and those states that's not going to be
days weeks months it's going to be years
and some of these kids are not going to
have a future as a result of those bad
policies you may not remember but the
very first interview we did
since we once we began to understand how
severe this was
you told me and i never forgot it that
you mobilized every single state agency
in florida
to protect the elderly to protect the
older
population in your state which is
significant yeah and so the results are
40 states have higher per capita
mortality for age 65 and up
compared to florida so we're one of the
top 10 safest states for seniors
we prioritize our seniors for
vaccination cdc was saying do
equity and political considerations i
said no way
if you're 65 and up we're getting you
the vaccine and i think we've done like
four million seniors who've been
vaccinated and places like publix
free of charge because they wanted to
take care of their community and you
know watch
and cbs and all these other that would
not have happened had president trump
not put the
pedal to the metal got those bureaucrats
in line
and said we got to come up with this
vaccine if biden had been president this
would have taken three or four years
to be able to develop these vaccines so
you think about we started vaccinating
seniors in december
uh we hit a million seniors in january
two million
february i mean those are lives that
were saved as a result of that
presidential leadership i think saying
president biden and warp speed their
direct opposites i don't think
anything's done
i'm just saying by the way the governors
are not going to be responsible for any
of the things i say as a talk show host
i give this disclaimer
um senator sununu um
that's my brother you can go talk to him
unrelenting
you know you have a state motto
live free or die yeah so the title of a
great book that came out before the
election i don't know if you heard about
it
i've read a cover to cover okay thank
you senator
um but in all seriousness
you made a lot of the same choices that
these governors made
the mistakes were made in new york in
new jersey in pennsylvania and michigan
and california
how is it they got everything so wrong
and
you nobody got it perfect because it was
it was imperfect yeah we were right in
the playbook right every governor had to
write their own playbook based on their
dynamics based on what we're seeing
new hampshire is a little different
because in new england we have all these
states that are really tight together
we're almost like counties
in florida almost so we had to work
together as governors for the most part
um and we did have to contend with new
york and even boston was
was in tough shape i think charlie baker
did a very good job frankly trying to
deal
the best he could with with what was
going on with the death rate in boston
and we're kind of the tax-free suburb of
that and we're kind of in the middle so
obviously
they'll live for your die state we
without a doubt led the charge on the
flexibility the opportunity
and now the economy right as governor
noam points out 2.8 percent i think we
have 2.77
unemployment i don't know the math is
changing
but we may be a little bit better we
have a show about debris
but but every governor had to write the
playbook and find
and it was about balance i think one of
the key issues that governors did very
well is you had to earn public trust in
the crisis early on
and you do that with transparency with
communication and when you do that and
you earn that public trust
as we're coming out of it they trust you
to make the right decisions coming up i
didn't notice any of you writing any
books in the middle of all this talking
about how great
leaders you are when making 5 million
bucks just saying um
by the way they want me out of new york
so just so you know but
but this matters though how if you're
going to be a leader the decisions you
make
for the people in your state under these
circumstances are hard
governor i remember in iowa there was a
moment one of your meat packing
facilities the same thing happened in
south dakota
and and i watched how you handled that
and it was
spectacular to be very honest because
you guys went right in it was like
a full court press and surrounded the
area and tell us
tell us about well first of all my
farmers and producers produce over 10
percent of the nation's food supply so
it was imperative that we kept our food
processing plants open
and we kept our grocery stores full and
meat on the table
for families all across this country and
so we were able to go in and do
surveillance testing
we were able to access a certain a large
number of tests so that we could not
only keep the processing plants over
open but we could ensure
the employees that they were working in
a safe environment not only did we
provide the ppe
but we were able to test those that were
positive were quaran
quarantined and we were able to keep our
processing plants up and going and i
mean
and not back up hog production for our
producers and we were looking at some
horrific numbers because the processing
plants
are were being impacted from covet and
so we hit it head on
we made testing available we were able
to implement a
really robust data program that really
allowed us to write down to a zip
code identify where the positive cases
were at and act
accordingly when new york was at its
worst i remember saying both on radio
and tv
if the manufacturers the medical
manufacturers the food suppliers
if they didn't manufacture right if the
packers didn't pack
and the drivers didn't the truckers
didn't truck new york would have died
that's right i mean literally you were a
lifeline for people in
really significant trouble at that time
and we were able to do it in a safe and
responsible manner we were able to keep
our economy open we were able to balance
the lives and livelihoods of iowans and
to do it in a responsible manner
and all of us were able to do that and i
think we're reaping the
benefits of that today because we're
coming back stronger than ever
uh from the pandemic and we have a lot
of opportunities in the state
number one state for opportunity i think
is what i where iowa ranks second
second fastest recovery from coveting
this is isn't it wonderful
this is everybody's going to be able to
should have done this in the octagon
we can all tell our we all have our
statistics right yeah
and by the way in fairness if you
compare them to any democrats it's much
better
uh governor ducey arizona similarly
a large population of older people right
you had certain challenges throughout
this pandemic but you were able to
overcome it how
well we focused on the vulnerable right
from the beginning
and we knew that was the older folks i
mean when governor lee says follow the
science we knew it was 65 years and
older
people with underlying health conditions
and this
this conference call that we would hold
as governors we came to some conclusions
that we were going to prioritize
lives and livelihoods and all of us were
going to err on the side of liberty
and limited government it was going to
be a light touch
we were going to listen inform our
citizens trust our citizens i believe
arizonans
have common sense and sean it was a
tough year i mean there's no winner
in a covered year but you want to do the
right thing so that your state can
navigate through it
and come out of it healthier and
stronger on the other side that's where
arizona is
we're leading the country in personal
income growth and if you don't like the
dry heat
you've got to check out flagstaff
arizona or the white mountains
that's actually a good point i remember
being out there one summer on a
walk outside of the radio station with
jd hayward that i'm like
i can't breathe it was it was really
rough
all right so all of you have this
problem the problem is
people from new york and new jersey and
california
and michigan they're leaving their
states
and they're going to your states you're
florida
seeing a huge impact of migration
out of the out of these blue states now
my only fear for all of you
i'll let you start first governor
desantis is that
they may bring their liberal policies
with them so it's interesting with
florida like the media at the beginning
of this said florida's bad
and i think it's because they wanted to
damage trump in florida they wanted to
damage me so they just kept saying it
was bad even though the facts didn't say
like literally last
april they're saying florida's doing
worse than new york new york was like 10
times worse
and so i think what it did is the people
that buy those phony
narratives for these these media they
they probably
aren't coming to florida but most people
see through it but the people that see
through it they think like us and so i
think a lot of these people are coming
i think they're registering as
republicans overwhelming and i also have
come across a lot of people
who quite frankly were democrats the
lockdowns turn them into republicans
because they say i cannot fathom i was
people say i was a democrat because of
education
and i'm in california and they're
locking my kids out of school
i come to florida they're in school
people are free people are happy
so i think this whole process has caused
some people to reevaluate
some of their prior commitments and if
you have a political party that puts the
interests of teachers unions
over the interests of kids being able to
just access an education at all
that tells you all you need to know
about the modern democrat party
well said governor gnomes
i actually have noticed i'm taking great
note
of the ads that you were running saying
come on to
south dakota we we openly welcome you
and specifically and you did the same
thing many of you have
with law enforcement we'll get to that
in a little bit but
you're saying this is an opportunity for
the state of south dakota to grow
and you are enticing people to come yes
we
you know i ran for governor on the fact
that i was going to bring the next big
industry to the state and i was going to
grow this state
that we wanted it to be a place where
our kids got out of school and wanted to
raise their families
they're surrounded by the people that
they love
what was interesting is i also ran on
south dakota being an example to the
nation
and what's happened during this pandemic
pandemic has allowed us to tell our
story
the thousands of people are moving to
our state and when you ask them
they say that they're moving there
because they want to live somewhere that
the government
respects them they want to live
somewhere they can be free
south dakota wasn't on their radar a
year ago to move to
but it is now and and they wanted to
live where they could have a quality of
life and they'd be respected we did one
week
of a national advertising campaign to
law enforcement officers
and told them if you want to live
somewhere where you're supported
where people respect you and we'll help
you take care of your families and be
successful come to south dakota
and in that one week we had hundreds and
hundreds of applications from 41
different states
of law enforcement officers that said i
want to live there because i know
they truly respect law enforcement and
they'll appreciate my service and i know
you governor gave an incentive you
actually gave a bonus to everybody
uh tennessee now i love nashville
because i live
90 miles south off i-65 when i was in
huntsville alabama and i see the growth
the property prices of soaring
opportunity is soaring business music
city
right usa tower cranes everywhere out
there yeah exactly a lot happening
but it's but it's florida it's texas
it's south it's all the states i don't
want to
single all of them out here but these
states are all growing and benefiting
what is the key component is it liberty
is it freedom is it low taxes
a combination i think that
people from all over this country are
looking around
unsatisfied in many states
the ones that we all know about with
life in particular
life in the last year and they've been
they've been looking for a long time
but suddenly this the differences
between our states and those blue states
are stark you know their kids have been
out of school for a year in tennessee
all of the kids are in school in fact we
have a strong
school choice wearing masks they're not
wearing masks
in a couple districts they are we have a
law in this state that allows districts
to
make that decision but i've said i don't
think any kid ought to wear a mask
why if you want to follow the science
you wouldn't have kids
in a school wearing masks when kids
do not get sick from covid that's
science and that's what we ought to be
doing but
school choices in states like ours
parents get to choose
tennessee's the third lowest tax per
capita state in the country
we just announced two major ecd moves
enormous companies that have decided to
move one from california
one from michigan to put their locations
here in this state
we're our regulation uh in this state
is really different than it is in these
states that have actually increased
regulation
our taxes have been reduced we cut taxes
this year
those states have so i love joe saying
if you take any money
he says oh you can't take money and cut
taxes in your state
they've had to pull back on that but i'm
like really because
we offer tax cuts to our citizens so
there's a combination there's a company
that's like the chamber of commerce for
everything yeah but but i'm actually
describing
a lot of republicans i agree with you
yeah there's a lot of
republicans right here who cut taxes who
have lower regulation who have choices
for parents who have
a business environment that's attractive
to business that's why
every single one of these states
including mine you know u-haul says
they measure trucks going in that don't
come out
and tennessee's number one for that we
all have our statistic
there's a stark difference in this
country that has surfaced
that we all in america see now and
that's why the migration we've got to
take a break but that's
that is the phenomenon i know that for
california if you rented a u-haul to go
to texas
you pay like 2 500 bucks if you had
taken a u-haul from texas to california
you could basically get it for free
unbelievable
all right one with our governor hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else